I previously told you that Nazi
Holocaust denier Arthur Jones was
running unopposed in the Republican
primary for the Illinois third
congressional district seat in the House
of Representatives this is a pretty
reliably blue district and they had
their Democratic and Republican
primaries a couple days ago on Tuesday
and Arthur Jones who is again a vile
anti-semite history of Holocaust denial
he received more than 20,000 votes from
Republicans in the district and there is
no way to question the guy's views right
his campaign website has a slideshow of
pictures of him speaking at white
nationalist events the anti-defamation
league has warned people about him even
the Republican Party of Illinois
disavowed Arthur Jones and 20,000
Republicans voted for him now I started
doing some math and I thought okay
there's about seven hundred and twenty
thousand people in the congressional
district close to three percent of them
went out and voted for a Nazi and that's
the total district right never mind how
many of those seven hundred twenty
thousand are registered to vote and then
of those how many are Republicans that
even would be voting in the Republican
primary I'm wondering and I don't know
the number what percentage of
Republicans in the third District of
Illinois went out and voted for a guy
who didn't even need their vote because
he was running unopposed and now Jones
is going to face the Democratic
incumbent Daniel Lipinski sort of a
socially conservative Democrat who did
not win easily on Tuesday he did win but
not not by a giant margin and the
defense I'm hearing from most people is
that listen David a lot of people just
go out to vote because they vote as a
regular thing and that's good and if
they're Republicans they're just gonna
vote for whoever is on the ballot if
there's only one Republican and that's
why they voted for Arthur Jones and
Democrats would do the same thing if
there was only one Democrat running
unopposed on the Democratic side and my
reaction to that is yeah it's true for
many people and it's really really sad
right the best case here is that there
are 20,000 people in the district
that will vote for any Republican
regardless of what they stand for even
if they have Nazi views which is really
really sad the other side of the
spectrum would be there's at least
20,000 Republicans who deliberately went
out and voted for a guy with Holocaust
denying anti-semitic Nazi views but this
stuff happens right David Duke a former
KKK Klansmen got almost 60,000 votes in
Louisiana Senate primary in 2016 and
forget about the the number sixty
thousand six hundred and fifty thousand
people voted for the serial accused
child sex assault or Roy Moore just a
few months ago in Alabama special Senate
inaction election so it shouldn't strike
us as hugely shocking and the story
isn't so much there's a Nazi running as
a Republican right because the the guy's
unopposed and the Republican Party has
disavowed him etc the real story here is
how many Republicans would vote for a
nazi over a Democrat the answer seems to
be many although we'll really kind of
get the final numbers in November on
that but hey listen it would be wrong to
say any of those Republicans are racist
because that's SJW identity politics and
that's a really bad thing to do or
something we can't say any of these
people could could even remotely be
racist like there are no good explainers
for this either people showed up at the
voting booths and just like an R next to
Arthur Jones his name and checked him
off yeah or they'd rather vote for the
neo-nazi and the white supremacists over
a Democrat yeah I don't think there's
any favorable reasoning that you can
have for voting for this guy there
really is then of course we don't know
yet whether they'd vote for the
Republican Nazi over the Democrats since
this was just a primary but we will find
that out in November and my prediction
is that we're going to find the results
really really disheartening and we will
lose even more hope and the future of
democracy in the United States as a
result I look forward to reporting that
to you on November under what day is the
election in November this year so thanks
there the first Tuesday first Tuesday
after the first Monday or something yeah
anyway we'll find out eventually when
Election Day is this year and I'm sure
we'll come to you with that breaking
news very very soon today's program is
made possible
in part by wink spelled WI and C I like
wine but I don't really know how to
select a bottle of wine and that's what
wink does wink makes it easy to discover
great wines that most importantly you
will like because every month they ship
you wines match to your tastes and
personalized to you now you might be
saying well hold on how do they know
what I will like very good question you
go to their website you go to try wink
comm slash Pakman and you fill out this
very short palate profile quiz they will
ask you questions such as how do you
like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and based on the answers to those and a
few other questions you will get great
wines personalized to you and delivered
right to your door as you drink more
wine which I know many in our audience
do and you rate more bottles of wine
wink learns and you get even more
personalized delicious wines for next
time no membership fees skip any month
cancel anytime
and there's a 100% satisfaction
guarantee so you will not pay for a
bottle you don't like and for a limited
time you can get 20 bucks off when you
go to try wink comm slash Pakman that's
t ry wi and c comm forward slash Pakman
for $20 off check it out